après la désastreuse adoption au forceps
de la contre-réforme des retraites vous
avez donc bricoler avec le président
Macron les 100 jours nous y voilà pour
quel résultat vous vouliez gagner du
temps pour vous-même vous en avez fait
perdre au pays et aux Français vous
promettiez aux Français 100 jours
d'apaisement vous les avez plongés un
peu plus dans l'épuisement épuisement
face à l'inflation et à la crise du
pouvoir d'achat épuisement social
évidemment après la réforme des
retraites épuisement face à la crise des
services publics de la police à
l'hôpital comme si cela ne suffisait pas
vous avez ajouté un épuisement
démocratique toujours plus de
verticalité et la promesse enterrée de
légiférer autrement refusant par exemple
nos propos de nos propositions
transpartizanes sur les déserts médicaux
avec Guillaume Garraud sur EDF avec
Philippe Brun ou sur le grand âge et à
la place toujours plus de 49,3
épuisement républicain enfin avec votre
obsession à délivrer des brevets et
arabourgeir l'arc républicain alors la
seule question qui vaille pour vous
Madame bien plus que pour vous mais pour
les Français y a-t-il une vie heureuse
après les 100 jours
député Jérôme Guedj j'ai envie de
rechercher Jérôme
et oui parce que
il se trouve qu'aujourd'hui il se trouve
qu'aujourd'hui il me revient de d'avoir
de la mémoire pour nous de monsieur le
député au bout des 100 jours le plein
emploi vous dites qu'elle prend quel
progrès pour les Français plus de
mobilité professionnelle plus de pouvoir
d'achat du meilleur emploi le bon emploi
qui va avec le plein emploi monsieur le
député j'ai la mémoire pour nous deux
nous étions sur ces banques au nous
votion des budgets de 2 ou 3 milliards
pour la rénovation thermique la première
ministre vient d'annoncer ce dimanche 7
milliards supplémentaires qui s'ajoutent
au 25 milliards déjà engagés dans le cas
de la planification écologique vous et
moi aurions je le dis je le dis et vous
en souvenez parce qu'au fond vous avez
de la mémoire nous aurions salué ce type
d'annonce en disant que ça allait dans
le bon sens que vous est-il arrivé
monsieur le député pour ne plus pouvoir
le reconnaître est-ce que c'est la
nupcation qui vous a rendu aveugle au
progrès pour les Français je me pose la
question vous parlez de l'hôpital
monsieur le député nous étions dans la
même commission le budget annuel accordé
à l'hôpital était de 18 milliards de
moins que ce qu'il est aujourd'hui avec
Emmanuel Macron reconn aissait les
progrès le dédoublement des classes
bientôt l'extension des horaires de
cours vous y étiez favorable je me
souviens des discussions que nous avions
l'un et l'autre sur ces sujets que vous
est-il arrivé monsieur le député-gage
ouvrez les yeux rejoignez rejoignez
cette majorité il n'est jamais trop tard
nous portons des progrès pour les
Français vous auriez tout intérêt à vous
en rendre compte
quand vous regardez sur votre gauche ce
qu'il y a à voir ne fait pas au vieux
français je suis sûr que je vous ai pas
oublié